Goldie Hawn emotionally reacts to the  death of Garry Shandling was such a  shock the comedian died at 66 years old  on Thursday and Hollywood is in mourning  including the comedian's former co-star  and friend Goldie Hawn the actress  teared up while speaking with et on  Thursday reflecting on Shandling's life  and legacy I'm not as happy tonight I'm  gonna miss it  it was such a shock and you deal with it  you know it's life and it happens to  everybody one way or another but when  somebody passes that special in you love  it hurts  so that's what I feel about that we'll  miss him off Shandling and hawin  co-starred as husband and wife in the  2001 film town and country are you  thinking of him right now just memories  going through